So this story is going to be partially funny.
Uh, and it's going to be partially serious
because there are funny things to talk about
here and serious things to talk about.
Um, there are numerous social media groups
and accounts and pages targeting both the
David Pakman show and the majority report
would Sam Cedar claiming to target us from
the left, which have cropped up recently.
One such group. This is just an example. Okay.
Just to give you a sense of what I'm talking
about. One such group as a Facebook group
called Progressive Against Sam Cedar and David
Packman. And there are some funny things on
page. For example, if you look at the header
image, uh, a cartoons of Salmon, I a word
bubble from Sam saying Joe McCarthy, 2020
and me saying yes please. Then there's another
group called Anti Mccarthyism, Progressive
Unity Against Sam Cedar and David Packman.
And of course there are endless Twitter accounts
which I mute when I see them because I don't
have time for them. And Youtube comment movements,
pylons, which are, um, lately targeting Sam
and me from the so called progressive indie
media.
But sometimes they're targeting more people
too. So sometimes salmon, I will be targeted,
uh, including Kyle Kalinsky from secular talk
as being part of the problem. Sometimes Kyle
is part of the solution, but Sam and I are
part of the problem or sometimes they will
uh, include Tom Hartman as part of the problematic
leftwing media along with Sam and with me.
But sometimes Tom Hartman is the right type
of progressive. He's on the good side of the
line, but Sam and I are on the wrong side
of the line. But the point here is that who
is on which side of the line changes and it
depends hugely on which so called progressives
are drawing that line and that's not hugely
surprising. Now I'm trying to think of like
how do I even start with this? Because when
you see something like this progressive's
United against David Packman and Sam Cedar,
there are a bunch of obvious questions that
we should be asking.
Question one is, are these groups really people
who are on the left who dislikes salmon, who
disliked me or are they rightwing astroturf?
That's a question to be asked. Second, who
is it that these so called progressive support?
If Sam and I are the problems who are the
right progressive's that should be supported
occurring according to the people who are
creating these groups, targeting salmon targeting
me. And thirdly, what does it mean about the
progressive movement? That more and more stuff
like this type of infighting and targeting
is cropping up. So here's the common trends
I'm seeing when you look at the Anti David
and Sam pages, number one, many of them have
a ton of pro Jimmy Dore content posted as
examples of the right kind of leftism. Okay.
So if we look at progressive's against Sam
Theater and David Pakman, a whole bunch of
the posts are Jimmy Dore Clips, which I believe
is meant to imply that Jimmy's the right kind
of progressive in Sam and I are the wrong
types of progressive.
So right off the bat you start to get a picture
of this anti Sam and David Movement, um, as
as at least partially unpro Jimmy Dore Movement.
Often these pages, and particularly the Twitter
accounts also have a lot of pro Tulsi gabard
content. If you don't know Tulsi Gabbard,
she is a presidential candidate currently.
Polling about 0.6% I believe. So that's another
sort of trend that exists and then typically
there's a lot of uh, Russia gate denialism
that is in a lot of these anti David Anti
Sam pages along the lines of we can't believe
anything molar says other than when Mueller
said no collusion. But all this stuff about
obstruction and election interference and
wikileaks is involvement from the Mueller
report. That stuff we don't believe, but we
can definitely trust Mueller that Trump did
nothing wrong. So I'm not going to go back
and attack any particular wing of the left.
I'm not going to accuse certain leftists of
not really being left because that would be
furthering the problem that these groups are
sort of indicating exists. Here's my main
point. If the left continues to do this, the
left is going to continue to fail on many
fronts. And I brought this up on the Joe Rogan
program two weeks ago and a bunch of people
misunderstood what I was saying. When people
come to me and they say, David, what's the
real problem with the left? It's not SJWs.
Okay. It's not campus free speech suppression,
it's not toxic identity politics. Those things
exist and they do exist in bits and pieces
on the left and I call them out when I see
them. But the real potential problem on the
left is defining the left so rigidly that
it will fail to accomplish anything major
because it will keep out way too many people
who share most of our goals.
And there's a really good article by Joshua's
sites and politico from June 1st called progressive's
should read progressive history so they don't
blow it this time. And it points out that
there are major problems to solve right now
in American society, in the American economy,
but if progressive's want to achieve change,
we need to understand how past movements have
succeeded. And the article looks at the progressive
movement of the early 19 hundreds and it looks
at the new deal coalition of the 1930s and
it also looks at the conservative coalition
of the seventies and eighties which was really
successful for conservatives. And I won't
go into the specifics of the three movements
right now, but the general thing they did
right is they were inclusive of people who
disagreed on some of what should be the agenda,
but they agreed on enough of the important
stuff that they were able to get really important
change to happen.
And that's my real concern about the progressive
movement right now, and I'm going to talk
about this at the end of the week in audience
questions. The lines are being drawn too narrowly
and people who could work together on, for
example, 70% of their agenda or 80% of their
agenda are going to end up doing nothing because
they're concerned about making pages, targeting
other people on the basis of the 10 or 20%
that they disagree on one example, okay, small
but growing is this divide on the left between
social democracy and socialism. It's a great
debate. Philosophically. It's a great debate
economically. I'm glad to have that debate.
Social Democracy versus socialism. I've and
I've engaged in that debate on the show. The
US is not going to become socialist anytime
soon and before the u s will have a reasonable
possibility of becoming socialist. It's going
to have to move significantly in the direction
of social democracy.
The reforms that are possible in the immediate
are reforms that are social democracy reforms,
which should appeal to the actual socialists,
socializing, healthcare, raising the standard
of living for the bottom via taxation at the
top and to financial transactions that add
no value to the economy and education. What
is the point in redirecting energy away from
making those changes which both Social Democrats
and Socialists agree on? In order to debate
and draw the lines between, you're either
with the socialists or you're against us.
This is stupid. Okay. The left will lose if
that's what they do. Let me give another example
that applies to me. I am against intervention
in Venezuela 100% I've said it a hundred times,
but I also think that the Chavez Maduro regimes
have been terrible for Venezuela. Okay? We
agree on the left almost 100% about being
against military intervention in Venezuela.
And yet when I bring up by, by the way, I
don't like Maduro and Chavez and here's why
and I think that they have been disastrous
plunderers for Venezuela.
All of a sudden I'm on the wrong side when
it comes to the intervention piece and people
are ignoring the fact that I'm right here
with you. I'm against military intervention
in Venezuela. Let's work together on that
because the debate over Chavez and Maduro
has less, uh, in terms of immediate consequences
then that about American intervention in Venezuela.
So let's table some of the less immediately
relevant discussions. Let's actually get stuff
done that we all agree about and let's not
draw the lines too rigidly because that's
the problem I see on the left. Not Free speech
campus stuff or SJWs or whatever those problems
exist. I call them out the relatively small,
but anyway, have fun with the Anti Sam Cedar,
Anti David Pakman groups. But you are doing
damage to the movement. Unfortunately.